المواقف الصادره ميم بيونغ رفعت من مستوى
القلق لدى كوريا الجنوبيه التي سارعي وزير
دفاعا الى عقد اجتماع طارئ لكبار قاده
الجيش ونقلت وكاله الانباء الكوريه
الجنوبيه عن وزير الدفاع لجونسون قوله ان
تطوير بيوم بيان للاسلحه النوويه يهدف الى
تدمير السلام الذي تعزز اصول قدراتها
للحفاظ عليه وحذرته من ان بلاده لن تتردد
في الرد بقوه وحسم اذا ارتكبت كوريا
الشماليه ما سماه استفزازا مباشره ونقلت
وكاله يوناب للانباء عن الوزاره تحذيرها
من ان اي محاوله لاستخدام الاسلحه النوويه
ستؤدي الى نهايه حكومه
بدوره وصف الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي اليوم
استمرار سلسله التجارب الصاروخيه والنوويه
التي تجريها كوريا الشماليه بانه عمل
الاستفزازي ونقلت رويترز عن يوم قوله ان
على جيش بلاده مواجهه استفزازات كوريا
الشماليه برد واضح